near russia's border with europe drills
involving ballistic missiles
a scheduled exercise but more propaganda
pictures from russia doing nothing to
ease tensions
[Applause]
in westminster prime minister boris
johnson addressed mps on the crisis and
hinted at british troops being sent to
the region if ukraine is attacked by
russia
if russia invades ukraine we would look
to contribute to any new nato
deployments to protect our allies in
europe and if russia pursues this path
many
russian mothers sons will not be coming
home
america has eight and a half thousand
troops on standby to deploy to ukraine's
neighbors if it's attacked more american
munitions and equipment arrived in kiev
part of a 200 million dollar military
airlift from the us
while allies continue sending security
assistance to the region the message to
ukrainians has been don't panic the
government telling them the situation is
under control and an invasion is not
imminent while everyone tries to guess
moscow's next move
but vladimir putin's intentions are
still a mystery is he waiting for
weather cold enough to favor a ground
invasion or is he still hoping diplomacy
will deliver concessions
tensions are being felt from the black
sea to the baltic where denmark is
strengthening nato's forces after 20
russian vessels put out to sea
latvia's prime minister told sky news
russia's leader must be made to feel the
pressure
what's important is that that we have
the sanctions prepared and that that
nothing is off the table that everything
is is possible and that that leaves a
that leaves also room for uh putin to um
change his plans or step back from
actual military force if russia makes a
military move it will have dire
consequences for the russian economy for
the russian people
for now russia's military continues
limbering up in the snow performing for
the cameras while the west does what it
can to deter it from being used in anger
dominic waghorn sky news kiev